où je les ai mis quand je vais me
promener au bord de la mer je pars
pourtant jamais sans mes horaires de
marée j'ai dû les laisser à l'atelier
tant pis j'y retourne
[Musique]
ah le voilà ce petit livret contient
tous les horaires de marée l'heure à
laquelle elle est hot et l'heure à
laquelle elle est basse et figure
également le coefficient de chaque marée
plus le chiffre est élevé plus la marée
est grande
autrement dit que la mer monte haut et
plus elle se retire loin
ces données changent tous les jours et
d'une année sur l'autre
elle varie également en fonction de
l'endroit où nous ne trouvons pour la
même journée la haute mer a lieu à 5h03
à noirmoutier et à 7h37 au mont saint
michel
un sacré boulot les premiers horaires de
marée au monde ont été publiés en 1839
pour le port de brest est calculée par
un scientifique français antoine
chazalon
[Musique]
à propos à quelle heure la mer sera
t-elle haute aujourd'hui
18h08 ce nous laisse le temps de nous
plonger dans cette histoire de marée
[Musique]
c'est important surtout ici à
noirmoutier sur la côte vendéenne la
presqu'île derrière moi et reliée au
continent par une route qu'on appelle le
gua et qui à marée haute est totalement
submergé pour mieux savoir à quel moment
se produit le phénomène chaque année des
promeneurs et des pêcheurs à pied se
font piéger
heureusement qu'il y à des refuges tout
le long de la route
ben oui c'est pas fait pour les mouettes
bon il ya bien un pont mais c'est moins
authentiques
alors qu'est ce qui provoque les maris
mais bien là on va faire avec les moyens
du bord de mer vous l'avez sûrement déjà
entendu dire c'est la lune qui est
responsable de la marée et pour cause
dans l'univers tous les corses attire
c'est la loi de la gravitation
universelle tony
si je lâche ce galet il tombe parce
qu'il est attiré par la terre mais lui
aussi attire la terre beaucoup moins
évidemment puisque la force de
gravitation dépend de la masse des corps
et de la distance qui les sépare à cause
de la gravitation la terre attire la
lune et la lune attire la tête sous
l'effet de l'attraction de la lune les
océans se déforme l'eau se soulève et
forment un bourrelet à l'origine des
marées attention précision importante la
marée haute ne se forme pas à la
verticale de la lune à cause du relief
sous-marin du tricot de plus ou moins
s'ils ne la marée peut être hôte avant
ou après que la lune soit à la verticale
à une dernière chose
cette attraction des formes également le
sol terrestre même si on ne s'en rend
pas contre à notre échelle c'est quand
même amusant de se dire que lille
derrière moi se soulèvent de 20 cm à
marée haute
mais là le phénomène se déroule vraiment
quand la lune est à la verticale ce qui
est en train de se passer en ce moment
six heures plus tard quand la terre a
fait un quart de tour et que noirmoutier
se trouve loin de la lune c'est marée
basse et encore six heures plus tard
quand la terre a fait un quart de tour
supplémentaire
c'est à nouveau marée haute la deuxième
de la journée alors que la lune se
trouve aux antipodes
ça c'est un peu plus compliqué
suivez-moi les marées sont en fait la
résultante de plusieurs forces il n'y a
pas que l'attraction de la lune
vous savez la terre tourne sur elle-même
tour complet en 24 heures elle tourne
aussi autour du soleil
une révolution en 365 jours et la lune
fait le tour de la terre en un peu plus
de 27 jours
si la terre et la lune faisait la même
masse les deux tournerait autour d'un
axe situé à mi chemin mais comme la
terre est plus massif que la lune
l'acce de rotation se trouve plus proche
du centre de la terre tellement proches
qu'il se trouve à 1700 km sous la croûte
terrestre
c'est ce qu'on appelle le barycentre en
tournant autour de ce barycentre la lune
fait le tour de la terre mais la terre
qui tourne également autour du
barycentre dessine de petits cercles
à cause de l'inertie ce que l'on appelle
communément la force centrifuge l'eau
est déporté elles forment alors un
second bourrelets qui se trouve aux
antipodes de la lune et qui est l
origine de la seconde marée rouge
prennent l'air mme hou la la mer s'est
retirée drôlement loin aujourd'hui c'est
normal c'est une grande marée et ça
c'est à cause de celui dont on n'a pas
encore parlé
le soleil à cause de sa masse trois cent
mille fois celle de la terre lui aussi
exerce une attraction
mais bon comme il se trouve à 150
millions de kilomètres de nous la force
de marée qui l'exercent est deux fois
moins importante que celle de la ligne
c'est la vie quand les trois astres sont
alignés comme ici la terre la lune et le
soleil les forces 7/10 yonne on assiste
alors à des grandes marées et des marées
de vives-eaux comme l'on dit en revanche
quand les trois astres forme un angle
droit comme ici les forces se
contrarient et on assiste à des petites
mares et des marées de mortes-eaux et
les marées d'équinoxe
à pour ça et bien faut que je retourne
dans l'atelier
[Musique]
c'est à cause de la position de la terre
par rapport au soleil
ce jour là le centre du soleil se trouve
à la verticale de l'équateur
l'attraction qui l'exercent est plus
importante que d'habitude
ce phénomène se produit deux fois dans
l'année le jour du printemps et nos
jours de l'automne et si le jour de
l'équinoxe la lune et le soleil sont
alignés avec la terre eh bien on assiste
à des marées encore plus grande
souvent on parle de marée du siècle à
l'erreur ah ben non
à force de parler la marée haute
maintenant la fin alors que les gens
viennent de l'inde à quelle heure la
marée est basse
environ une heure plus tard c'est normal
la terre fait un tour complet sur
elle-même en 24 heures
pendant ce temps là la lune qui tourne
autour de la terre se déplace légèrement
par conséquent il va falloir un peu plus
de temps pour que noirmoutier se
retrouve à la même position par rapport
à la lune ça vous fait marrer aller à
très bientôt
tiens à propos de marée connaissez vous
l'origine de l'expression contre vents
et marées elle remonte par la marée
l'expression au xviie siècle
c'est une métaphore qui signifie agir
avec obstination
malgré les difficultés rencontrés
lorsqu'ils sont en mer les marins love
souvent faire face à des éléments
contraires qui perturbe la navigation et
qu'ils doivent affronter pour rejoindre
la terre ferme au sens figuré
contre vents et marées signifie donc
aller au bout sans renoncer malgré les
obstacles qui se dressent sur la route
al'inverse au 16e siècle l'expression
avoir vents et marées et est souvent
utilisé
elle signifiait être favorisée par les
circonstances
à bientôt et bon vent et marées
[Musique]